[Music]
the urgency of the kovit 19 pandemic
spurred a worldwide response
from government to business the arts to
science
innovations big and small were critical
for many people's
survival tremendous breakthroughs have
occurred in the scientific community
advancements in mrna technology could be
critical for cancer treatments of the
future
in colombia artisan clothing makers were
left without customers after the
pandemics shut down tourist hot spots
but new collaborations are helping these
craftspeople bring their heritage styles
onto modern platforms
and as monkey pox cases spread around
the world
what lessons from the covid19 pandemic
will apply
and which ones won't
in the microbial world the two pathogens
that cause monkeypox and covid19 have a
few things in common they're both
viruses for starters which means in some
ways they aren't really even alive
the virus particle per se is
biologically inactive
but as soon as it infects a cell or a
host organism it starts as genetic
program and then it multiplies it
mutates it recombines and these are all
signs of life so the particle is
biologically inactive but as soon as it
gets into a cell i mean it will become
biologically active and this is a sign
of life
another thing the two viruses have in
common is that they have jumped from
animals to humans
in the case of sars ko v2 the original
host is thought to be a species of bat
in east asia despite its name the wild
host for the monkey pox virus is thought
to be a small mammal possibly a rodent
that's indigenous to africa
what are known as spillover events with
what are called zoonotic diseases are
growing more common
the increasing human population
requires
more food
which also then translates into more
livestock
requires more room
and it's a highly mobile population so i
think we have probably more spillover
events in the first place
because of this uh higher frequency but
then also the possibility for epidemic
or pandemic spread has increased
drastically
despite those basic similarities though
the viruses that cause the two diseases
are pretty different for instance in
terms of how they store their genes
the monkeypox virus is a dna virus
its genetic instructions are written on
a long double-stranded chain of
nucleotides
the coronavirus that causes covid19 on
the other hand is an rna virus the
instructions for making it are written
on a much shorter single-stranded chain
because dna is more stable than rna the
monkeypox virus doesn't mutate as
quickly as rna viruses like sars cov2 do
we've seen this ascot too that
selective pressure put onto the virus by
for example vaccination
can result very quickly in the so-called
escape mutants on the other hand i mean
the the human pox virus that has been
eradicated by 1980 i mean this did not
really change at all during all this
eradication campaign
monkey pox is a fairly close cousin to
the virus that causes smallpox starting
in the late 1950s the international
vaccination campaign that wiped out that
terrible disease ended 20 years later so
many younger people nowadays are
unprotected but medications that could
theoretically help treat monkey pox
already exist and the two pox viruses
are close enough relatives that experts
think even people who received smallpox
vaccines decades ago should still be
fairly safe if you did get your
vaccination you still have a certain
limit of protection of course this is
dependent on the individual reaction
onto this first vaccination but it's
definitely the case that vaccination
against the human pox virus also
protects or cross-protects
against infection by the monkey box
virus
another big difference between the two
pathogens is how infectious they are
people with covid19 can spread the
coronavirus easily via aerosols to those
around them without close physical
contact for days before they show any
symptoms themselves
in the past monkey pox patients usually
didn't even catch the disease from other
people but from animals indicators are
that more human to human infection is
now likely taking place with monkey pox
but it's still simply harder to catch
than covid19
the monkeybox virus is transmitted by
very close contact
to infected individuals there are two
issues which are important one is that
it's not as easily transmitted as sask
of two and the second as far as as we
know at least so far um there is no um
transmission before symptoms actually
arise
so there are big differences in the
genomes of the two viruses which affect
how fast they mutate but also
differences in how prepared we are to
fight the unexpected outbreaks they have
caused
that along with the fact that the
monkeypox virus simply doesn't spread as
easily as sarsko v2 makes most
healthcare authorities cautiously
optimistic that monkeypox will be easier
to contain
[Music]
south africa's fifth wave of coronavirus
infections is cooling down
although most restrictions in the
country have been lifted the numbers of
new infections as well as
hospitalization rates remained lower
than during previous waves
but in the past few weeks many parents
have still noticed that something isn't
right
the western cape authorities around cape
town call it an unprecedented pediatric
surge
our correspondent adrian kriesch has
more
[Music]
man
usually i'm a bit reluctant to give my
kids medicine when they just have a case
of the sniffles but the past two months
have been a nightmare when one is
getting better the other one is getting
sick over and over again and after
several doctor visits we now own a
private pharmacy
this one is the strawberry medicine
and this one
is for allergies
and this is something if you get fever
and this one is something to spray in
your mouth like this
in the past weeks we went to see a
doctor like five or six times it's just
heartbreaking to see the little ones not
getting better at all and we are not the
only ones who are having that problem
sticking to a day-to-day work schedule
has been hard for most parents who send
their children to this preschool where
attendance has no stiffed
we've had less than 50 over the last two
months
and on and off you know
parents will send their children back as
soon as contagion stages are over
um but then it seriously takes two or
three days and then they're with another
virus you know adeno rsv or whatever it
may be so it's very very very difficult
for parents and staff alike
so you got your brother's illness as
well
claudia gray has been overrun with
patience in the past weeks the
pediatrician blames the number of
viruses that are currently going around
and then we'll take this
all right okay thank you
okay
herbert is still around and every single
day i see covert patients still and
they're generally presenting with high
fevers in children the other virus
that's been very dominant is the rsv
virus and it's our classical bronchitis
that's fairly serious
some kids are ending up being admitted
for nebulizers or intravenous fluids and
often kids are sick for three weeks with
this illness the other virus we've seen
a lot of is one called the adenovirus
which is one of our enteroviruses intro
means gut so this particular virus is
very clever it can affect your gut it
can cause a flu-like illness and
classically fevers for even up to 10
days
and lastly what's now coming through in
the last week or two is the flu virus so
covert flu
rsv and adenovirus and in between that
of course just the common cold viruses
but these viruses are having a party it
is typical for more kids to get sick
during this time of year grace says
after all it's the beginning of winter
and the weather is getting colder but in
all her years she has never seen such a
surge
the last two years have really been a a
lull in viral spread because of all the
measures we've taken for covert
prevention social distancing masking
hand washing have been strict lots of
online schooling so kids haven't had
those bunched up play dates and
socializing and time in kindergarten or
primary school to be in each other's
faces so to say so our immune systems
have not seen many of our usual viruses
for a long time and they're sort of out
of training so now when we see these
viruses which are fairly standard
viruses we're almost overreacting to
them because our immune systems are no
longer fit and trained to fight them
quickly
at least my kids can have a little break
from the cycle they are healthy again
and happy to be back to preschool
many of their friends though are still
at home with the holiday season coming
up pediatricians are hoping that this
will break the cycle of infections it is
likely that next year will be a lot
better after their immune systems have
strengthened but for now i know i am not
the only parent crossing my fingers
the success of mrna vaccines in fighting
against the sars cove ii virus has
pushed the technology into the spotlight
it's also showing promise in fighting
cancer by tailoring the medication to
target individual tumors
our reporter christina kufna finds out
more from oncologist niels halama
hello professor
great to speak to you
you treat cancer patients which means
you also have to give them the diagnosis
how does it affect people when they find
out that they have cancer
it's a life-changing experience for
patients to receive a tumor diagnosis
it always involves massive stress as the
threat and fear of a tumor is a heavy
burden not only for the patients
themselves but also for their families
and loved ones
such a diagnosis always involves the
immediate question as to whether the
illness is still treatable
whether the tumor can be removed
or whether it's a situation in which the
tumor is so far advanced the treatment
only prolongs the patient's life
after going over the options
we then discuss a way of moving forward
with mrna technology and the cancer
vaccine we've entered a new era
mrna technology that's something we've
heard a lot about in connection with the
coronavirus how could it help cancer
patients
the development of mrna technology
actually came from the field of oncology
from cancer therapy
the idea behind it is to use mrna as a
molecule to precisely support a
patient's immune response
that means the process is the same as
with the coronavirus
a blueprint so to speak is sent to the
body and with this blueprint the body
recognizes the cancer cells and it can
fight the cancer cells better than
before
that's right
the major advantage of mrna technology
is that this vaccine can be established
very quickly for an individual patient
for a single tumor
and this blueprint this information that
is packed into the mrna can then be used
in the patient very quickly to stimulate
the immune system to target the tumor
unlike the coronavirus vaccine where
everyone gets the same mrna vaccine that
is the same target structure the tumor
vaccine is personalized
the approach tries to specifically
stimulate the immune system for the
individual tumor and position the immune
system to destroy the tumor
can it be used for all kinds of tumors
all kinds of cancer
you have to understand that in the first
step
we discover the tumor is achilles heel
what are the tumors characteristics that
can be used to construct a vaccine
against it
when you have enough material from the
tumor to examine the genetic material to
be able to find the mutation
then you can construct the vaccine
can it be used as a preventative measure
like with the coronavirus vaccine you
get a jab to reduce the risk of becoming
infected is it like that in this case
it's still very much up in the air one
of the major differences is that the
vaccine that's used in oncology in
cancer treatment is a therapeutic
vaccine
that means that a tumor already exists
and that the vaccine is ultimately used
to fight the tumor
as it does indeed have a major influence
on the patient's overall condition
but also on the question of whether a
vaccine might help or not
you have to understand that when the
tumor emerges and spreads to other
organs such as the lungs or the liver
that means the patient's condition has
worsened significantly
there are simply many more tumor cells
the immune system has to fight
it has to be active and fight on all
fronts so to speak
it's harder for the immune system to
become active against all the parts of
this entire complex tumor development
side effects are an issue that many
people deal with which potential side
effects could arise from this kind of
vaccine
side effects typical of vaccines can be
seen
such as muscle pain cramps
fever or mild fever
all these things can happen
but honestly
compared with chemotherapy
or a classic checkpoint immunotherapy
these side effects are very minor
and the vaccine is highly tolerable in
that sense
so it's really a ray of hope for cancer
patients when might the first vaccines
be approved
that's a difficult question
there are several studies running
parallel and of course much depends on
how significant the effects are with
such a vaccine
if they are very significant and drastic
with a disease that's hard to treat
then the path to approval would be much
quicker
i believe that broadly speaking we'll
probably know more in two years
surely we'll know more
but we might also have the first
approvals if all goes well and the
results are very clear
professor thank you for the interview
you're welcome
tourism has been especially hard hit by
the pandemic
including in colombia where most holiday
destinations were shuttered as infection
rates soared
for small businesses that rely on
tourists that was a bitter blow
with fewer buyers local craftspeople
were left with a lot of time on their
hands
so many began to innovate
[Music]
here in the mountains of colombia
staying warm and sheltering from the
cold is critical
but these garments called ruanas are
more than just practical clothing
they're a tradition that new weavers are
keeping alive
the colombian ruana is a work of art
behind a craft is firstly the emotions
of those who do it because we capture
how we live what we're going through now
what we've seen and what first inspired
us to do this
we started with an idea and wanted to
capture it with our craft
rafael learned the trade from his
grandfather who also earned a living
selling his creations in local stores
lockdowns during the pandemic caused
sales to drop
the people who would come to our town on
weekends to events that are organized
here stayed away
tourists come to buy things to visit and
get to know us
so the closures affected the economic
part of our workshops a lot
in bogota a similar situation was also
playing out with shops closed silvia
adrade a designer based in the colombian
capital wondered how to get through the
pandemic
the best option was to close the store
unfortunately
we loved the store it had been around
for a long time and was very successful
it was a sad decision but it was also a
good one because we knew it was the
right thing to do at the time
during the pandemic sylvia began working
with artesanias colombia on the viva
fashion collection project she trains
artisans in digital marketing and social
media
we talk about trends we talk about the
world of fashion we talk about
sustainability and natural dyes
different types of information that can
help them improve their products more
and more
we create a concept and discuss topics
that are of interest to everyone
and above all speak to the community
the classes helped raphael ladino learn
product photography and how to use
social networks as a sales tool
at that time
to colombia was a great ally
they gave us support and advice
suddenly we had time to learn more
technical basics about photography
marketing and design
many of us working inside shops
previously did not see these as options
because we were only working
producing
and selling
rafael now uses social networks to sell
his products today half his income comes
from online sales but the goals of the
project don't end there rafael and
sylvia are working on a new collection
i've already had the chance and pride to
see some of my products on the catwalk
in photographs and types of spaces
where you think
wow there they are
this latest collection will be exhibited
at one of the most important craft
events in the country
rather we are guiding collaborative
communication the conversation with the
communities
we work together to come up with a
product
what we want is to show the world that
this hidden beauty exists
and that infinite possibilities exist to
work with these techniques and with
these communities
rafael's dream is to make these fabrics
known around the globe so everyone will
recognize the magic and warmth of a
colombian ruana
do you have questions about covid19
dw science editor derek williams will
answer them with the latest research and
analysis
write to us at covid producer dw.com
this week's question from our viewer
carlos alves
do vaccines stop transmission of the
virus
[Music]
no
they don't but even if that sounds like
a simple answer
it really isn't that's because the
epidemiological picture right now has
grown
seriously
complicated um billions of doses
of different vaccines have been
administered now to people
in different combinations
the alpha and the delta variants have
been
kind of outgunned in most places by the
much more highly transmissible
omicron variant
well over half a billion cases of covet
19 have been confirmed and there are a
lot more many in people who've been
vaccinated multiple times
and plenty of people have been infected
more than once in other words
there are no clear-cut groups anymore
like there were in the earlier days of
the pandemic where where researchers
looked at categories like
like post-infected and uninfected or or
vaccinated versus unvaccinated there are
now
just billions of us with our own
individual particular histories
of covet vaccinations
exposures
and infections
one thing that is clear is that current
vaccines don't stop transmission of the
virus which is a big reason why experts
no longer really talk about reaching
herd immunity
if you can get sick with the disease
despite being vaccinated or recovered
and then pass it along to others
potentially multiple times then herd
immunity becomes
an unreachable goal
there's still a lot of debate
about whether
fully vaccinated people transmit as much
of the virus as unvaccinated people do
while they're infected but for me
that's kind of splitting hairs
no matter what your vaccination status
if you contract coped 19
you could potentially
pass it on and advice on isolation from
all leading health care authorities
reflects that
if you test positive for sars kobe 2
they say
you should go into isolation for a while
to keep from infecting others there's no
extra exception for people
who are vaccinated and had breakthrough
infections
however that still doesn't mean that
vaccination has
zero impact on transmission first and
foremost as the world health
organization writes because
if you're vaccinated you're less likely
to get the disease you're less likely to
incubate it and you're less likely to
infect someone else so
by preventing infection in the first
place you're lowering exposure in
society
as a whole
some researchers also think that having
a vaccine-induced immune response will
also make you on average
less infectious and for a shorter time
but as i said
that's still up for debate
[Music]
this show we've seen what new
developments have arisen or become
prominent as a result of the pandemic
both in medical and economic terms
and how what we've learned can also be
applied to other areas
next time we'll take another look at the
consequences of covet 19 for the
environment
that's all for this week thanks for
watching please join us again next time
and until then stay safe
[Music]
you